when it comes to anime and especially
battle Shonen let's be real we are here
for those huge finishing moves and big
impactful moments things like ban Kai
and devil fruit Awakenings and
Transformations or special abilities
these are those exciting moments that
get us hooked on a series they give us
the drips of dopamine that we need to
keep the monkey in our brain banging its
symbols together so we can keep going
and in Jujutsu Kaizen we have domain
expansions but of those which is the
best of the best and why let's talk
about it welcome back to anime uproar
I'm your host for today's video axle
beats and today we're going to be
ranking the domain expansions from
weakest to strongest as well as giving
you a general overview of what each of
them can do and some of these are pretty
nutty so I'm gonna try and have a good
time if you enjoy this video and want to
see more content like it remember to
leave a like to show support or if you
want to help us out go ahead and leave a
comment down below with ideas for future
videos that you'd like to see either
about Jujutsu Kaizen ranking abilities
or even other series that might be
popping off that you think we should
check out and of course you're gonna
want to subscribe so you don't miss any
of the great stuff coming your way
finally this video will obviously have
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned before we
get into the actual list let's talk
about just what domain expansions really
are they can be super varied and unique
but in general they do have a set of
rules which they all follow in some way
or another basically in most cases I
like to think of it like locking someone
in for a nen battle if you've seen
hunter hunter or a stand confrontation
if you've seen JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
they can be Unga Bunga sometimes but
they can also be incredibly thought out
and complex as well domain expansions at
their core are kind of like a
combination of a barrier and a person's
innate being barriers in Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen come in their own variety of
shapes and sizes as well well but there
are more or less walls that have rules
applied to them and the more strict that
those rules are the stronger the wall
can be for example if you make a barrier
with the specific rule that one person
cannot enter it will be incredibly
effective against that individual but if
you have a more General barrier that
affects everyone equally it will be much
less powerful in comparison conditions
could also include other things like
size for example and in most cases you
could expect a barrier around a small
area to be stronger than one around a
large area now this idea of a barrier is
the first real component of a domain
expansion how big of an area it will
cover how many people it can take in how
strong is the sorcerer or curse creating
it these all kind of play into how hard
it is to escape an opponent's domain
once they set it up that said in some
cases the domain expansion user might
even opt to not set up a barrier around
the domain at all adding to the risk
that the enemy might escape and meaning
that they could increase things like the
range or power of their ability instead
it is all a balancing act now the second
part of the equation is the person's
innate being their innate domain as it's
called domain expansions are quite
literally just that an expansion of the
space that a person takes up an
extension of their psyche and abilities
we'll see this later in the list but for
example mahito needs to touch people to
activate his abilities however
regardless of how far they are from
mojito themselves everyone in his domain
is considered to be in contact with him
they are in his space and thus he has
contact with them even if his body is
not touching that person directly most
domains have abilities or rules similar
to this offering guaranteed hits to all
of their abilities and while these
attacks can be deflected destroyed or
overpowered at the very least they
cannot be avoided on top of this whoever
is creating the domain also gets a huge
power boost to their own abilities while
inside it as well those are the basics
of what domains are and how they work
there's obviously more specifics to go
into in each individual case but in
general that's what we're looking at but
with all of that out of the way we can
get into the actual rankings here and I
do kind of feel the need to add a bit of
an Asterix here more so than many other
anime abilities domain expansions fall
into that category of things like nen
and stance where even the weakest
ability can offer Niche uses which make
them incredibly powerful we aren't
working with Brute Force most of the
time and because of that a lot of it is
left up to interpretation and situation
so while number one and number 10 might
be drastically different in terms of
power numbers four five and six for
example might be fairly interchangeable
on the list and an argument could be
made where any one of them is better
than the others you can almost look at
it like a tier system where things in
tier 3 might be interchangeable with
each other but wouldn't compare to tiers
two or one and starting off the the list
we do have a few honorable mentions
these three characters uro Ryu and Yuta
are all known to have domain expansions
but we just don't have any detail on
them as of right now they might be
ungodly powerful or they might be
completely pathetic we just don't know
and because of that we can't place them
properly but the weakest of the users
that we do know is pretty undoubtedly
the smallpox deity the smallpox deity is
a special grade curved Spirit summoned
by pseudo ghetto using his curse Spirit
manipulation it was kind of acting as a
test for him to really gauge how
powerful a grade 1 sorcerer's ability
could be and to see if they were even
worth wasting his own time on them its
domain expansion graveyard domain sees
it slamming its fists into its palm and
causing coffins to fall from the sky and
lock its Target inside if they can't
escape after a few seconds they'll be
infected with smallpox and ultimately
die now obviously like many of the
domains on this list this can be pretty
lethal but the effectiveness and
malleability of this ability are the
issue here firstly the coffins
themselves do not kill the target
meaning if the person can keep breaking
out they aren't really in danger second
the smallpox deity isn't exactly the
strongest or smartest on his own so it
more or less automatically targets
whoever the strongest source of curse
energy is around itself it's an
automated system that can only affect
one enemy at a time and only once every
few seconds and thus it is kind of
exploitable for example in its fight
with Maymay despite her being the
strongest threat overall when UE Powers
himself up it makes him the Target and
opens an opportunity for meimei to
exercise the curse don't get me wrong
this thing is definitely a threat
especially in a one-on-one fight but it
just isn't versatile or really powerful
in comparison to the other things on the
list and I think that's something
important for me to reiterate here is
that none of the abilities I'm talking
about today are weak by any means it's
like I'm saying that they're the least
talented person at the Olympics they are
still incredibly impressive but the
competition is just more so at number 10
we have hiromi higuruma who is a defense
attorney who took on cases mainly trying
to protect people who were wrongfully
accused he inevitably became Jaded by
the justice system completely and we see
that reflected in his domain expansion
deadly sentencing deadly sentencing
creates a small courtroom domain
surrounded by Guillotines where he and
his opponent are placed across from one
another this is a fairly unique domain
expansion that isn't inherently lethal
in most cases domains are used
specifically to be able to kill the
opponent but in higuruma's case it seems
to be more about incapacitating people
and lethality becomes a last resort
while this domain does not offer a
guaranteed hit anyone inside of it is
forced to follow the rules of the court
case the most important of which being
that violence is not allowed and that
anyone inside must take part in the case
this case has three relevant people
firstly judge man a shikigami created by
the domain expansion as his name
suggests he is the judge residing second
is the prosecutor higuruma and third is
the defendant being whoever he is
targeting judgments things that he knows
everything about the lives of all people
within the domain he will present
higurumo with one piece of evidence and
the defendant will have to prove
themselves to be innocent in the eyes of
the Court by either lying telling the
truth or staying silent however if there
is no hope for the defendant they can
always try to plead guilty and pray for
a lighter sentence now the evidence that
higuruma receives is not exactly
clear-cut he won't know the full context
nor the full situation so hypothetically
the playing field should be more or less
even but as higuruma is a practice
lawyer he just inherently has an
advantage on this kind of situation as a
whole though this is just very much a
debate in which the defendant is arguing
for their innocence and higrumah is
trying to push charges on them and judge
ban will be the ultimate Arbiter of who
wins in the end after this judgment can
give a verdict and a sentencing if he
sees fit for example we see him
confiscating yuji's cursed energy if
judgment gives a death sentence higuruma
will receive an executioner sword
something which will guarantee to kill
anyone that it cuts instantly so in
general this domain expansion is pretty
strong in its own way but it just isn't
exactly lethal firstly he has to win the
court case which can go either way
second even if he does win the actual
sentencing is kind of out of his hand if
judgment confiscates cursed energy that
can be a huge Advantage but if the
person is strong or fast enough on their
own it might not even need cursed energy
to beat higuruma in a fight and even if
they are sentenced to death judge man
doesn't kill that person himself he
gives higuruma a sword and then he has
to land a hit with it the biggest
problem with deadly sentencing is that
nothing is guaranteed I don't think any
domain in the series offers quite so
many opportunities for the Target to
actually Escape or succeed and that's
why this is so far down on the list at
number 9 we have another special grade
curse Dagon Dagon is born from the fear
of water-based natural disasters and
this is a super big domain expansion
that actually doubles as a base of
operation for ghetto and the other
curses which to be fair it takes the
form of a pretty gorgeous Beach which
sounds like the best evil villain base
that you could hope for but despite the
beautiful setting this domain expansion
The Horizon of captivating skanda is
surprisingly lethal here Dagon is able
to produce a countless amount of sea
monsters and fish shikigami that he can
launch at anyone within his domain this
is a guaranteed hit ability within his
space and Dagon is even able to split
this to Target multiple people at once
this is one of the simplest domains on
the list it's just a cool beach where he
throws fish at people and there isn't
really much to it other than it solely
being an offensive attack but at the end
of the day someone who's fast or strong
enough can just get around it or
overpower it as much as the Simplicity
of the domain expansion is nice it's
also kind of limiting in terms of
options next we have megumi this is the
first incomplete domain expansion on the
list meaning it doesn't have a
guaranteed hit ability on top of that it
also doesn't have a barrier and unlike
with sukuna making the most of not
having a barrier Mega me not having one
is kind of objectively a weakness
specifically because of how his ability
works at its core Shadows make up the
majority of Mega meets Arsenal being
able to use the 10 Shadow technique to
produce different shikigami that are
extremely versatile to assist in all
kinds of situations and building upon
this idea is Chimera Shadow Garden the
area that Mega me is in becomes flooded
with shadows it is very much like water
except it's just Shadow there's no
resistance there's no air and there's no
Mass to it meaning the opponent needs to
channel cursed energy onto their feet to
stay afloat or they will fall into
Infinite Darkness below them in this
domain he can freely summon his
shikigami in stronger forms than usual
as well as creating shikigami clones of
himself it is a very scary and flexible
ability and honestly it would probably
be higher on this list if it wasn't for
the biggest flaw the lack of a barrier
as I said his ability requires Megami to
flood the area he's in with shadows
meaning it can't be used out in the open
if he could add a barrier to this it
would be able to be used anywhere but
instead he needs to find an enclosed
space and lure his opponents into it to
get the most of his ability on top of
this there's something that might be an
even bigger issue negami can only
sustain this ability for about half a
minute it is definitely a very powerful
skill but at the same time it has
glaring limitations on when and where it
can be used that hold it back now moving
back to more simple domain expansions we
have number seven which is jogo's coffin
of the Iron Mountain much like dagon's
domain expansion jogo creates an
environment however this one is much
more straightforward and has less
counter play Jojo locks himself and an
opponent inside what is essentially a
volcano with a temperature so high that
it stated that an average Jiu Jitsu
sorcer would burn to Ash immediately and
while there is more to The Domain that's
really the big player here things like
dagon's barrage of shikigami can be
deflected or fought off Mega means
domain is a 30 second Survival game
there's things you can do to protect
yourself in most of the domains we've
mentioned so far but with jogo's domain
expansion well it isn't exactly like you
can fight off heat once you're in you're
done unless you're someone who can
straight up overpower jogo's curse
energy there isn't really anything you
can do about it as with all other
complete domain expansions jogo does
have a guaranteed hit ability volcano
that he produces is made up entirely of
molten rock and he can launch or extend
this towards enemies to smash into them
so even if you survive the heat you're
going to be beaten down by Stone
eventually and like sure that's great
but it's not exactly the most impressive
thing that Jiu Jitsu Kaizen has to offer
and if you have people who are going to
withstand the heat they're probably also
strong enough to crush the rock as well
that said I mean Gojo and sukuna are
really the main examples we've seen
dealing with this so far so most people
would probably struggle more than we've
seen while this domain is definitely
lethal it again suffers from that
Simplicity issue where if plan a goes
wrong there's not really much else that
it can do so I think that I'm going to
leave it here at number seven next up we
have kinji hakari and Idol death gamble
possibly the most convoluted ability in
the entire series and maybe one of the
most dangerous as well this domain
revolves around the game of Pachinko
it's more or less a slot machine mixed
with pinball and a game of Plinko in
Pachinko silverballs will fall down a
machine towards the bottom where it has
a start chucker basically a small basket
between two holes and the more balls
that land in the chucker the higher your
odds of winning become on top of that if
you match two of three icons you can
enter a Richie timer which effectively
acts as an extra spin or spins to try
and get a jackpot of three matching
images but as far as is concerned for
hikari's Ability he's basically trying
to hit a jackpot in a game of Pachinko
and if he does he receives the bonus of
infinite cursed energy for a short time
when the domain is activated everyone
within it will immediately understand
the rules of the domain and this
information dump can also act as a mini
version of Gojo's domain expansion where
the person is fed so much information
they can't move for a moment it is a
much smaller version but it might last a
few seconds while they process things
it's nothing absurd though the domain
has a few stages it can run through the
normal stage puts he and his opponent in
a white space surrounded by turn Styles
as he bombards them with Pachinko visual
effects these can include colored doors
colored balls and consecutive spins the
color of the ball that he uses can
increase the chance of Hikari getting a
jackpot when he gets a Richie basically
the odds that the third icon will match
after a pair once he does spin a pair he
can enter a Richie scenario depicting if
he will get a jackpot or not now ideally
he would just select the color and raise
the odds as much as he can but they're
given to him at random however he can
use these colors to get an indicator of
his odds to succeed and if he ever sees
a gold ball he is extremely likely to
hit a jackpot on top of that the game
also has a Pity timer so if he keeps
losing he'll eventually get a rainbow
ball that will guarantee a jackpot then
you have things like chance boosters
which give him beneficial effects if he
does loops and all of that fits into the
first normal stage once he eventually
does hit a jackpot hikari's domain will
break apart and his reward for this is
infinite curse energy this means his
attacks become devastatingly strong and
if he gets hit by anything he will
immediately perform reverse curse
techniques to heal himself from that
injury and he basically becomes an
invincible Unstoppable version of
himself for about 4 minutes but here's
the thing once that timer runs out his
cursed energy levels drop from infinite
to his normal maximum meaning he can set
up another domain expansion and begin
the process all over again but there
will be a small change here after
hitting a jackpot for the first time
each day then next domain expansion will
not start in the normal Zone but instead
either places him in an increased
possibility stage or a faster spin stage
depending largely on if his previous
jackpot was because of an even or odd
number The increased possibility path
more or less guarantees another quick
jackpot especially when used in
combination with consecutive spins again
this allows him to get more infinite
cursed energy right away and repeat the
process again however the faster spins
can go back to the normal stage if they
don't hit jackpots so having explained
how that works at least as best as I can
I think I need to reiterate something
here some of the spots on this list
which not comparable to spots 1 and 2
for the most part are still unbelievably
powerful and an argument could be made
to place any of them above the others I
mean like I said akari effectively
becomes Immortal and Unstoppable once he
hits a jackpot for as long as his luck
continues to go and once he does hit
that jackpot he can manipulate that luck
Fair fairly effectively the only reason
I'm placing him here on the list rather
than higher is that he still needs to
hit that initial jackpot and in the time
that he's trying to do so he's still
vulnerable on top of that to make use of
his infinite energy his domain needs to
break apart meaning there are no
barriers or walls to keep his opponent
near him and Escape while unlikely is
still possible this domain expansion is
easily on another level compared to what
we've seen so far but these small
elements of unreliability stop it from
entering the top five and luckily as we
move into the number 5 spot we don't
have to talk about anything as confusing
as sakaris and instead we have ah
well at least there won't be too many
confusing ones after this time cell Moon
Palace thalia's domain expansion takes
the form of this weird uterus looking
fellow that launches unblockable film
gauges towards his enemies that apply
projection sorcery on a cellular level
the specific effect follows a system of
24 FPS the very very simplified version
is that anyone hit with disability will
need to act out 24 very precise actions
within the next second at the rate of 24
frames per second or they can choose to
remain totally still and make themselves
a Target on a macro level this could
include things as big as moving a finger
or bending a leg but in this case it
also registers movement at the cellular
level like I said so it's next to
impossible to really follow through with
for just about anyone and in the event
that you do failed to match this 24
frame system you are frozen in place for
a full second meaning that it can hit
you again and basically lock you in as a
sitting duck also a consideration that
you have to have here is that you can't
control every part of your body and
things like your cells don't regulate on
a 24 frame per second system so your
failure rate is just about 100 as some
part of your body internal or external
will be moving at all times the ability
has a ton of very powerful things going
for it being able to dictate someone's
movements being able to freeze someone
in place forcing your opponent to
overthink every action forcing them to
move at an irregular Pace there is so
much there and the only real weakness is
that people like Gojo might just be able
to either succeed or overpower the
cursed energy involved but like how many
people in the series do you really think
could keep track of all the things going
on and still be a threat my guess is
about two of them and the same ones who
would negate everything else on this
list of course if Hikari had infinite
curse energy he might be able to
overwhelm these effects as well but it
basically comes down to who gets things
off first and I think this is just a
more reliable ability overall this is
just insanely powerful very disorienting
and because there's no startup luck
factor involved I think it's going to be
placed just ahead of Hikari at number
five on to mahito in our number four
spot bajito is of course one of the big
bads of the series meaning that his
abilities are probably insane and his
domain expansion self-embodiment of
perfection is no exception ajito's big
thing is that if he manages to touch
someone he can reshape their soul and
disfigure his body any way that he sees
fit often turning them into horrific
constructs or monsters and it's just not
a good time however it does also have
the added benefit of him being able to
reshape his own soul and body which
effectively allows him to heal himself
or transform body parts into weapons at
any moment's notice which is kinda rad
now the big downside of his normal
ability is that he has to touch someone
otherwise was he can't transform their
soul or activate idle transformation but
as I explained up top the domain
expansion is an expansion of the space
that a person takes up and as such he is
immediately connected to the souls of
anyone within his domain expansion and
can freely transform them it's only real
weakness before is that he could be
avoided but now that's more or less gone
luckily that big bonus that he gets is
also kind of a downside in specific
situations as he is forced to touch
anyone's Soul within his domain so for
example when Yuji enters his domain
mahito is forced to touch sukuna's Soul
which is a bit of a No-No that leads
tsukuna to retaliate and cause enough
damage that mahito's domain collapses
later in the series we see him being
able to use his domain for 0.2 seconds
at a time which is fast enough to Target
others in the area without giving sukuna
time to react basically this domain is
more or less Unstoppable unless you are
drastically stronger than my which is
pretty rare or unless you negate the
effect like muda does but I feel like
unless you negate it it's kind of a dumb
excuse in this list and applies to
everything else that I'm talking about
as well so we're going to assume that
things go as planned the attack lands
and ultimately this will place him at
number four and that leaves our top
three starting with kenjaku an ancient
sorcerer trying to evolve Humanity
through cursed energy as he transplants
his brain into different people so he
can live long enough to see his dream
become reality kenjaku's domain
expansion is womb profusion this
produces a massive pillar of cursed
spirits but we don't really know a ton
about this ability other than that we
know that it is an open domain similar
to sukunas that it has a devastatingly
powerful guaranteed hit and that is able
to counteract powerful barriers and
simple domains fairly simply couple
those things together with the fact that
it is kenjaku's domain and you have
something that's going to be incredibly
strong the reason I'm placing it third
despite knowing less about it than
things like mahito or hikari's ability
is mostly related to kenjaku himself
likely having enough cursed energy to
overpower those characters and again the
randomness of hikari's domain expansion
is holding him back here as far as we
know kenjaku's domain is more or less a
point at someone and watch them be
obliterated kind of effect that also
stops others from protecting themselves
why transform someone or make yourself
stronger when you can just eliminate the
threat altogether and of course that
brings us to our second place entry
which was always going to be between
Gojo and tsukuna and personally I'm
leaning on sukuna as our number two his
domain malevolent Shrine is an open
domain meaning that there's no barrier
around it and anyone is free to escape
however by allowing for this weakness in
its design he extends the range to an
effective 200 meters from him and that's
where his guaranteed hit comes in and of
course having two separate forms
dismantle destroys any inanimate object
in that 200 meter range and cleave
destroys anyone who has any cursed
energy in that range this is more or
less instant so yeah there is no barrier
and people can escape however everyone
and everything within 200 meters could
be instantly killed the second the
domain expansion is used meaning that
the idea of Escape is never really on
the table it's more or less a false
restriction that gets him a massive
power boost and it's just incredibly
smart on top of that it's just very
straightforward and simple you don't
need to think too much about it he
doesn't need to launch fish at people he
doesn't need to drown people in Shadows
what does sukuna's domain expansion do
it destroys everyone and everything that
he wants it to that's it and you just
can't argue with Simplicity and
efficiency sometimes finally that leaves
us with Gojo in number one his domain
expansion unlimited void locks his
Target inside and then floods them with
so much information that they are unable
to process it basically it overloads
their brains so much and so quickly that
people stuck in the void for 0.2 seconds
are filled with half a year of
information and are unable to move for
five minutes it works out so that for an
average person to be stuck in there for
one second They will receive 30 months
of information and be unable to move for
25 minutes and that is for each second
that they remain in the domain expansion
and yeah while this domain is Bonkers on
its own you then have to combine it with
Gojo it is one thing to have someone
immobilized like nowia's domain does
albeit unlimited void also does so with
no real conditions but to have someone
immobile and vulnerable in front of Gojo
who is just straight up stronger faster
and better than everyone else and can
rip your head off if he wants to or use
his blue red red or purple techniques
and it's just game over from the second
he has you in there I will note that
unlimited void's biggest benefit Gojo is
also its biggest weakness because Gojo
is for the most part unwilling to put
civilians in danger fighting him in
crowded spaces effectively locks this
ability from being used in any really
effective ways it's why he was only able
to open the domain for 0.2 seconds in
Shibuya meanwhile if kenjaku or sukuna
had this ability it would probably be
used without any hesitation it sucks to
be the good guy I guess sometimes
anyways I think that's going to wrap
things up for this ranking video there
are a ton of awesome domain expansions
in jjk I'm definitely a sucker for
nowias and mahitos but let's be real
gojos is just so cool that it's hard to
argue with that one being the favorite
let me know which one you think is
strongest or which one is your favorite
and where you think I might have
misplaced people on this list remember
these abilities are largely situational
based on when and where there and who
the user is fighting and there's a lot
of leeway being given when considering
which is strongest within a close range
on the list like there are obviously
tears but within those tiers I think
it's pretty hard to know exactly where
things fit you know regardless if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more jjk content in the future remember
to leave a like to let us know and of
course you gotta subscribe so you don't
miss any content in the future there's
going to be a lot of good stuff coming
your way finally if you want to support
me directly you can check out my own
channel axelbeats where I just made a
massive six hour video on one piece but
with all that being said thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
I hope you all stay excellent